keepin it real greetings apiece welcome
to the Dean show how you guys doing
exciting episode every week if you're
like most people you have no idea you
hear it on the news we covered it before
military occupations are meant to be
temporary but after 40 plus years
this one looks permanent and entirely
unjust in the West Bank Israeli Jewish
settlers and Palestinians live on the
same land but must live under two
completely separate and unequal systems
of Israeli law the Jewish settlers
dominate the natural resources including
water and agricultural land and they're
backed by the Israeli army to maintain
the occupation
Israel has demolished thousands of
Palestinian homes and orchards
confiscated Palestinian lands farmed a
captive civilian population in Gaza and
punished resistance with raids arrests
and assassinations all to gain maximum
land while making life so difficult for
Palestinians that they will either leave
or be too afraid to resist Palestinians
have fought back for decades they tried
to achieve national liberation through
armed struggle some groups still do but
the majority now support the popular
protests instead
the deeply harmful pattern of control
repression and violence profoundly harms
Palestinians living under occupation and
Israelis living as occupiers this must
be broken to reach a peaceful and secure
future for both peoples now that you
understand the problem what about the
solution what about peace talks so far
over two decades of us-backed peace
talks have actually made things worse by
helping Israel continue the occupation
it's been years of talking while Israel
massively expanded the Jewish
settlements and literally redrew the map
peace talks are good if they're real but
not when they're theater to cover a land
grab so now what the current world
superpower the United States has been a
terrible friend in abling Israel's
destructive and self-destructive
expansion onto Palestinian land by
funding the Israeli military the biggest
recipient of US foreign aid in the world
but there's another superpower that can
make the difference you and we have an
expert in the area but like most people
you have no idea you hear Israel you
hear Palestine things blowing up up
there and you're like watching family
guy said I no time for that these are
these bosoms really trying to extinguish
all the Jews from the face of the earth
how do we know what's truth was
falsehood we're gonna be clearing up
some misconceptions getting to the
bottom of this with an expert we've had
him on the show before me copilot get
this his father was Israeli it's my
friend Miko father was a raised Israeli
general his great-grandfather one of the
original signers of the Declaration of
Independence so we got no fool on the
show we have an expert we'll be right
back people to come to us
welcome back to the Dean show guess who
my friend your friend Miko fill it how
are you Miko how you been I have been
great things it's good to see you again
good to see you also can use kind of
summarize that I hid it right your
father was a general in Israeli army
your grant your grandfather I said it's
like can you compare him to like a
George Washington one of the founding
fathers can you go ahead and lab right
on that so my my maternal grandfather
was one of the signers of the Israeli
Declaration of Independence he was one
of the early Zionists he was a leader of
the Zionist movement in the Zionist
movement so yes this is I come from a
pretty patriotic family yes now for the
people taking a break from the sitcoms
from the nighttime daytime drama and
they want to get into some history some
current events but like most people were
just ignorant about what's going on but
there's nothing wrong with you know if
you're if you're trying to learn so you
can overcome that ignorant right you
want it you want to grow you want to
learn and we have a Israeli Jew Jew
Jewish Israeli here someone who's an
expert scholar in this area to educate
us to educate me to educate you so give
us like a summary what's the whole for
the average person has no idea what is
going on over there why things just
blowing up wire you know and then you
have this term just terrorists you know
over there we're trying to you know all
the common man charters Wow can you just
in a nutshell like summarize bring
people up to speed how this started
what's going on I know you can talk on
this for four days but in a nutshell for
your comment person average person who
just has no clue well I think
I think it's important to limit
ourselves to Palestine and so that's
what I do not to try to overextend and
try to understand every single conflict
in the Middle East and every single
place and to punch them all together so
I'm ready to focus on Palestine which is
what I do it's what I know it's what I
understand and the the issue of
Palestine is really actually quite
simple it's a it's a it's a story of
colonization it's a story of oppression
it's a story of ethnic cleansing and
genocide
- which Palestinians have been victims
for 70 80 years now and the colonizers
and oppressors contrary to what people
seem to think or what people say in
mainstream media are these rallies other
Jewish immigrants who came to Palestine
like my grandparents who came at the
turn of the last century came to
colonize Palestine came to establish a
European state in land that belonged to
the Palestinians Arab Muslim land and
that is really the beginning of the
story that is really why there is a
conflict there's really why there's a
problem
naturally Palestinians tried to resist
so when they tried to resist the
oppression when they tried to resist the
confiscation of their land they are
called terrorists and this kind of fits
in with today's
you know that with today's demagoguery
and mythology that that demonizes
Muslims that demonize Arabs but the
reality is that for 70 years more than
70 years now Palestinians have been
victims of terrorism they've been
victims of genocide they've been victims
of ethnic cleansing and today all of
Palestine is governed by a single
government which is the Israeli
government it's not a democratic
government unless you an Israeli Jew if
you're Palestinian you live under a
completely different set of laws it's
more like an apartheid regime than
anything else and Palestinians are
resisting and they have a right to
resist that most of the time they resist
using nonviolent means most the time
they try to use diplomacy or they try to
use nonviolent means of resistance like
BDS boycott divestment sanctions and so
forth and using whatever means at their
disposal from time to time they do
engage in armed violence and that is the
reality and and they are always met by
terrible violence from the Israelis
Israel has a huge army it is
well-equipped equipped by the US with
the latest technology the latest
warplanes the latest tanks latest
artillery and Israel uses it
predominantly against Palestinian
civilians so that in a nutshell is the
problem that is in a nutshell as what is
happening in Palestine
and it's really relatively speaking
quite simple it's not it's not an easy
problem it's not an easy thing to fix
perhaps but it's really quite simple
what about for for many of the people
who say that look Israel loves freedom
unlike their neighbors Arabs want to
wipe us out right and and and many other
things that are said that look the
people there want to live in peace but
it's the Arabs you know the Muslims who
are just trying to wipe us out and this
is our instinct I try to do it before
they try and do it and out they're the
ones that are sending the bombs over
they're trying to blow us up what do you
say well it's factually not true
there's absolutely no evidence no truth
at all to any of those statements the
Palestinians were and still are the
victims of a cruel campaign of ethnic
cleansing the reason today we have about
five million refugees living Palestine
refugees and refugee camps that have
been there for almost seven decades is
because of the ethnic cleansing campaign
that Israel engaged in when it was
established in 1948 it was a long and
cruel campaign that lasted more than a
year where Palestinian towns were wiped
out wiped off the face of the earth
Palestinians were forced out of their
land and into refugee camps many
massacres took place many innocent
civilians were killed by the Israeli
forces so there's absolutely no proof no
evidence that supports any of those
claims that the Arabs or the
Palestinians want to wipe Israel off the
map that the Palestinians want to kill
it I mean there's no evidence and it's
never happened you know what did happen
is seven decades of what I call an
attempted genocide because when you kill
innocent civilians by the thousands as
Israel has been doing when you deport
those people by hundreds of thousands as
Israel has been doing when you deny
millions of people the right to return
to their homes when you deny people
water Palestinians even though they're
the majority of the population in
Palestine under Israeli control are
allocated only three percent of the
water
well denying people water is a sure way
to kill them other than shooting them
and so none of these claims are based in
fact where we actually look at the facts
we see that Israel has been the
aggressor the Palestinians have been
victims and the add Palestinians are
still quite willing and quite interested
in peaceful coexistence now from from
the perspective I mean I'm I'm a Muslim
you're Jewish Israeli and this myth a
lot of times has perpetuated that you
know islam teaches you know the hate of
jews but historically is that true i
mean from from the islamic perspective
you see like you know the the quran
honoring you know you have 34 times
mentioned you know this honor the people
of the book you have moses who is is one
of the greatest messengers ever sent to
man
he was the greatest messager in the Old
Testament in Islam he's mentioned over
136 136 times you had the medina charter
where Jews were given safety and they
were given protection so do they do
people know this do they know these
facts you know there is a professor I
believe from the that Journal
JC journal de David Warren Steen where
he said that Islam had saved the Jewish
people I mean when you know do do people
know these things that they know that
you know these facts are out there um
well I think I told you this before I
was born and raised in Jerusalem and
although I was raised in a part of
Jerusalem that was predominantly Israeli
Arab East Jerusalem is just you know a
couple miles away and Arabs Jerusalem is
a deeply Muslim City and my impression
growing up of Islam is from what I saw
in Jerusalem and it was an impression of
great beauty of kindness of hospitality
a warmth honesty sincerity that is you
know the beauty of hearing the call to
prayer you know from the mosques from
the minarets everywhere in Jerusalem
[Music]
acceptance that's that was my impression
of just as being the being of being a
young man and a kid growing up in
Jerusalem and and and knowing the
harvest Jerusalem particularly the old
city now historically the Jews have
lived in Arab countries and Muslim
countries very well and very peacefully
and thrived Jewish communities all over
the Arab world all over the Muslim world
thrived when Jews and many times when
there were persecutions of Jews there
was persecution of Jews in Christian
Europe they found safe havens in the
Arab world they felt safe havens and the
Muslim world and I think religiously
truth theologically to Islam and Judaism
are sister religions really they share
more in common than most other than
almost any other two religions that you
can think of and so again none that none
of these none of this violent and
intolerant image of Islam is based on
facts particularly not we're talking
about relationship between Jews and
Muslims and between Jews and most of the
Muslim world
none of this is none of this is based in
fact the fact facts point to the
opposite and when we talk to Jews old
Jewish people and Muslims who lived in
cities in Palestine before the State of
Israel before Zionism came we're talking
about people that the Jerusalem some of
the neighborhoods and the old city in
Hebron and some of these older cities
where Jews and Muslims lived together
for you know hundreds and hundreds of
years the stories always - all the
stories of Tolerance
the stories are always stories of people
getting together respecting one another
often all the Jewish people will tell
you how on the Saturday their Sabbath
their Muslim friends wouldn't smoke out
of respect for or denied fires out of
respect for the Jews who on that day do
not smoke and light fire as you know and
similar stories you know during Ramadan
where Jews would respect you know the
wishes
the feelings of their Muslim neighbors
those are the stories that you hear from
people who really lived were in these
mixed communities then if you want to
talk about stories of Jews and Arabs
Jews and Muslims who lived in proximity
in Baghdad in Yemen in North Africa in
all these other Muslim cities and Muslim
countries the stories are always the
stories of tolerance and great
friendship and great neighborly
relationships none of that other stuff
is ever happened you know now that stuff
is true and I can like I said none of it
is based on on fact or history how true
is this when you study is this something
documented it's I had quote I quoted the
professor David Warren Steen who
mentions this in in that Journal and you
have other prominent rabbis who come out
I've had my friend rabbi Weiss you know
rabbi Weiss they'd substantiate this
also and this kind of like you know it
brings down some of those barriers and
walls and clears that great
misconception like you know Muslims hate
Jews but I mean it's a fact now before
before history shows there's also
another example uh tell me if you know
about this you can elaborate on it
Albanians at the time when they were the
Jewish people were being world war ii
hitler was was persecuting and killing
the jewish people that the Albanians
were making documents and saying these
are our people that you were not going
to touch do you know and can you
elaborate on that I don't I can't
elaborate I have heard about it but I
don't know the details there but but the
stories of Jews finding refuge among
Muslims even within Europe not just a
move going out into Muslim countries but
even within Muslim communities even even
in Central Europe in places like France
where where Jews found refuge
in mosques and certainly in other Muslim
countries this is well known as
well-documented absolutely so what
happened how do you know the neighbors
who were together you know I heard they
would watch each other's kids it was we
have a long rich history of peace what
happened well what happened is
colonialism what happened was
intervention by European powers what
happened was the colonizing of Palestine
by Europeans and then they changed the
narrative you know a conqueror the
Conqueror always always always gets to
write the history and so the stories
that they invented were stories of that
for stories that perpetuated this image
of the Muslims and the Arabs as
irrational and violence and uneducated
and incapable of living together with
others and uncivilized and so on and all
this to justify the conquests to justify
this new order that the Caliph
scientists brought to Palestine and that
the Europeans after World War one and
created in the Middle East in order to
in order to maintain
colonized reality a colonized project
you have to justify why you are
oppressing the other you have to justify
why you're picking the other out of
their homes while you're killing them
why they arresting them you have to
justify it somehow so the way you
justified is by creating myths by
creating a different story now some 70
years later go back and start telling
people that it wasn't the Arabs of
Palestine that were attacking the Jewish
community was the other way around was
the Jewish community in Palestine the
Zionist community who came fully
intending to ethnically cleanse the land
and you know take that and take over
they came fully intending to destroy
Palestinian towns and destroy Palestine
as an Arab Muslim country and take over
and create this European colony there
which is what Israel is so yeah you have
70 years of this of this mythology that
has been perpetuated here in the West
it's been persuaded here in the United
States when you look at schoolbooks here
in America history schoolbooks what do
they say about the Middle East what do
they say about the ancient Middle East
all of these stories perpetuate the
smiths that today's Jews today's
Israelis are the descendants of the
ancient Hebrews you know even now after
the United Nations passed this
resolution condemning Israel for
building settlements in the West Bank
the Israeli Prime Minister these are the
ambassador's are going back and saying
we lived there you know 2,000 3,000
years ago and so on and so forth which
is all mythology you know none of us
European Jews are descendants of ancient
Hebrews it's a complete myth but the
story is perpetuated the story is told
very well it's a good story the story
the deed to accept
and they're very good at telling it
they're very good at pushing their
agenda and pushing their mythology to
justify their agenda that's what
happened so people lose track of what
actually took place
now we're not again talking to some
laymen this is my friend my co-pilot the
general son father was a general in the
Israeli army great-great-great
grandfather grandfather one of the
original signers of the Declaration of
Independence we got an expert in this
area
Mikko do you get a lot of heat speaking
up for the oppressed do you do do you
have a lot of backlash because of your
strong voice for justice not to be
honest no I don't not at all I mean I
get invited to speak where I get invited
to speak I you know I I don't suffer any
backlash at all but the opposite I mean
wonderful people and great friends like
you this has been great little warts
speaking and I don't really feel that I
speak for the oppressed that you know
that I speak for my friends my
Palestinian friends who are living under
very harsh conditions but when you know
Palestinians even in the most harsh
conditions Palestinians who live in Gaza
where they're denied water and food and
and there's malnutrition you know for
the first time in Palestine in Gaza and
things like this I look at my friends I
look at people that I know I speak to
them there's nothing oppressed about the
are strong and their spirit is strong
even though they're suffering a great
deal if you had a chance to sit with
Larry King if you've ever met Larry King
and you got into a discussion with him
how do you think he would respond and
what would you say to the term
institutional discrimination here the
institutional discrimination and how do
you think the conversation would go
between you and Larry King well I was
born and raised in a country that that
has institutional racism the State of
Israel is an institution is based on its
institutional racism institutional
discrimination of favoring Israeli Jews
like myself over Palestinians or other
native to the people of the land where I
was born and raised and when I'm in
Jerusalem where I live is a completely
different reality both legally in terms
of the laws that govern my life the
environment the amount of water that I
get the opportunities that I have it is
completely completely different in a way
that is privileged
when Palestinian friends of mine who
live sometimes no more than you know 10
15 minutes away so institutional racism
an institutional discrimination is the
basic foundation of the State of Israel
so I was born I was raised with that
I've seen it all my life living in
America there is also America wrote the
book about institutional racism America
was was was was established
on the foundation of genocide of the
native people and in slavery and there
is no worse institutional racism and
discrimination and slavery and of course
the reality of of blacks in this country
and people of color in this country has
always been one over institutional
racism so in a way every country always
ever lived in almost has been you know
has had institutional racism as part of
its reality what are the common
responses to what you're saying and how
do you respond to those well the common
the common comments are that
Palestinians are terrorists and Israel
has no choice but defend itself
the Jews somehow have some kind of a
historical rights and a moral right to
take over Palestine and creditor states
even if that means infringing upon the
rights of Palestinians because Jews have
some kind of a special case because the
Holocaust and so forth you know I think
it's really quite simple it's a question
of values if you believe that one person
has more rights than anyone else because
of their race their religion their color
their nationality their gender whatever
if you believe that one life is more
valuable than another I remember after
the massacre in Gaza in 2008-2009 it's
called the Israelis called it cast let I
was in Palestine during the time and
then I came back to the US and I was
getting talks about it and after a
certain talk I think I was in San Diego
and members of the Jewish community came
up and criticized me for speaking up
like this and criticizing Israel and I
said to them you think that it's okay to
kill a child if you think it's okay to
drop bombs on innocent civilians then
there's really nothing to talk about
because the conversation is over it's a
question of values and if you asked me I
would tell you even if the devil himself
lived in Gaza
it wouldn't justify harming a single
hair of a Palestinian child in Gaza and
now you're telling me it's okay to kill
civilians and kill children because
there's this thing in Gaza Kassam mass
it's a question of values there's
nothing to argue about you either think
it's okay to drop bombs on civilians and
kill children or you think it's wrong
there's no justifying it there's no gray
area it's the same with racism either
believe you either racist or you're not
or you oppose racism there's no gray
area here so my response to people who
come up with these claims who say you
know whether they're saying that you
know blacks deserve less or that Muslims
are terrorists or the Palestinians have
no rights or the Jews have more rights
and Palestinians it doesn't really
matter how its framed it all stems from
the same racist beliefs well if somebody
has racist beliefs that's their values
there's really nothing to argue about if
you believe that this is right that's
the end of the conversation it's not
politics so as I said earlier it's
really a very simple reality it's really
a very simple situation and if you look
at your values and you examine your
values it's gonna tell who's gonna show
you which way to go
you know it's really quite simple that
my values point me in one direction and
obviously other people's values point
them in a different direction and
there's nothing to argue about
give us a live story because the people
there have been dehumanized so put some
put a human face to it I mean from a
live experience and if somebody we had a
Christian via an Israeli a Jew wanted to
go over and meet some Palestinians to
make that human connection which is so
powerful you know share with us some
real stories you know that people can
can can that that good from every human
can come out because that dehumanization
has really taken blinded a lot of it
well it seems perfectly natural to me
designed when I'm at Ellis time with
Palestinians all the time you know I
sleep I go to sleep at friends houses
where Palestinians
Palestinian towns and Palestinian
villages and cities and from online
episodic and billion I mean places that
are in Palestine all the time
I sleep in their homes I eat with their
families i we said in no light and we
talk about things used in a big circle
in a village and you know drink tea and
discuss politics I mean this is
something that I do and all the time and
it's interesting to talk about
Palestinians as being as less than human
are being savages across the street we
have Israeli settlements Jewish towns
that steal their waters that sit on the
land of these Palestinians of this
Palestinian village they take the water
of these Palestinian people that have
served in the army that arrests them and
shoots them and often arrested shoots
and tortures their children yet the
Palestinians are are called inhumane or
savage or terrorists and they've never
engaged in violence they've never they
never had an army never there's never
been a Palestinian army policy intent so
so to me it's perfectly natural I do
this all the time I mean I'm I'm with
Palestinians in their homes in their
towns and their villages in their cars
and in cities everywhere and all the
time and all I ever experience is this
friendship and kindness and warmth or
you know indifference I'm just another
person who's coming and going and doing
doing whatever I do we just had a
conference a wonderful conference last
month in November in the village of Abu
Saleh so there are Palestinian speakers
I spoke there was a group of people who
came from the u.s. some of the people
came from the US had never been to
Palestine so this is the first the first
trip
you know every night we set together we
talked then and so on - lately the
latent at night we stayed in Ramallah
for a few days it's it's it's it's an
excellence a wonderful experience I
encourage everybody to go to Palestine
and does it Palestine and and travel at
Palestine it's very easy to travel it's
inexpensive it's friendly you're always
gonna find somewhere to eat and sort of
sleep and and and and a friendly face
and that is the reality of Palestine and
people who do go to Palestine or do get
involved with the struggle for justice
in Palestine always come back with the
same impressions of how kind and warm
and friendly and and you know easy to
travel and so forth Palestine is and and
Palestinians are as a people trying to
ascertain the truth and we have the son
of Israeli general my friend Miko pilet
here helping us to remove much of this
ignorance on what's going on over there
and tell me Miko how much money is
actually spent here our tax dollars are
sent over there and what is it is it to
help the poor what's going on with the
money that's said you know because we
got a lot of you know people here who
you know we got challenged in America
that are upside down and we can use some
money here but what we what the taxpayer
wants to know what's going on with our
money over there well Israel gets
largest for an h-back for an aid package
from America than any other country and
Israel
developing nation Israel doesn't heed
foreign aid doesn't deserve foreign aid
doesn't need for me it's a wealthy
country to a strong economy so why is it
that the u.s. gives billions and
billions of dollars to a country that
doesn't need it every single year as a
mystery there's a question that the
American taxpayer has to ask because
these are American tax dollars going
there what the money is used for is is
to purchase weapons and kill
Palestinians it's as simple as that
Israeli army is huge it's well-equipped
and the only really the only people that
that suffer are the Palestinians and
they suffer directly from this foreign
aid now besides the foreign aid the
fight all this taxpayer money that goes
to Israel there are tax-exempt
organizations that support the Israeli
military would support Israeli
settlements that support all kind of
groups within Israel Jewish groups that
go in and steal Palestinian land and
take Palestinian homes and we're talking
about billions and billions of dollars
on top of the foreign aid we're talking
about money that comes in from
from tax-exempt organizations American
tax-exempt organizations so they're
exempt from tax but they're using the
money in order to support settlers in
order to support terrorizing
Palestinians in order to support the
Israeli army even more and
president-elect Obama's son-in-law is
one of them he's on the board of the
Friends of the IDF and they give
millions and millions and millions of
dollars to the Israeli military which I
believe is no more than a glorified
terrorist organization so why is it okay
for them to give material support to the
IDF which again is material support to
an organization that is engaged in
terrorism and whereas the Palestinians
who give charity to Palestinians and do
not give it to any kind of military
organization but give to charity are
accused of giving material support to
terrorism this is a double standard here
that is that it's impossible to
understand but there's a reality in
America that says that Israelis are poor
and they deserve money and I don't know
why that is and it's it's time to end it
because number one American taxpayer
money is going to do terrible things
which makes Americans complicit in some
terrible crimes and number two these tax
exempt organizations are not paying
taxes and they're sending millions of
dollars to do very bad things so why are
they getting why why are they getting a
tax exemption and why is the u.s.
missing out on all this again millions
and millions of dollars of money that
should be paid in taxes and again it's a
vicious circle it needs to be brought to
an end and somebody's got to stand up
you don't agree to this anymore we're
not gonna give any more money to Israel
Israel doesn't need it doesn't deserve
it and besides it using the money to do
terrible terrible things can you explain
to us what's going on with the settlers
moving in well it's actually a lot more
simple of it all the Israelis are
settlers we all came from somewhere and
took Palestinian land if not us
personally then you know our parents our
grandparents so all Israelis are
settlers and they're all sitting on
Palestinian land stolen Palestinian land
usually when they talk about settlers in
that in this context they talk about the
settlers who did the say the exact same
thing took Palestinian land and are
living on it in the West Bank which is a
small part of Palestine that Israel
occupied in 1967 you see the occupation
of Palestine took took place in two
parts the larger part of Palestine
eighty percent of it was occupied in
1948 when he's always established and
then the smaller part of it which is the
West Bank was taking over twenty years
later so as a two part process and for
some reason only the Israelis only the
Jews were living as banker called
settlers the reality is wrong all these
relative settlers all the Israeli towns
and cities are illegal settlements and
should all be and treated as such so but
but that's what Israel does Israel is a
settler colonial in state it's a settler
colonial country it's acceptable on your
project it's all about taking the land
away from the population to whom it
belongs the native population of the
Palestinians and allowing Jewish
immigrants to take over to receptors to
take over this is what happens all over
the palace life all over the country and
of course people call it is really
refused to call it Israel I think we
should call it Palestine which is what
the country is called
but that is what takes place everywhere
pause teens are being kicked off their
land so that Jewish towns can be built
Jews only talk about exclusive
exclusively Jews being you know being
allowed to live on the land to use the
land to build roads on the land and so
on and so forth and according to Israeli
law the vast majority of the country can
only be sold or leased to Jews Nikko
before we come to a close to an end this
wonderful session my good friend Miko
Pillet the general son you got to get
the book will tell us the there is no
such thing as Palestine Palestinians are
people coming from the outside we've
been here three thousand years what do
you have to say about this well I don't
know who's been anywhere three thousand
years the story of somehow the today's
Jews particularly today's Israelis are
somehow the descendants of this ancient
tribe that lived lived there 3,000 years
ago the ancient Hebrews
there's no proof historical proof that
that's true there's certainly no reason
to expect that it's true I think if you
look at the color of my skin and the
color of the skin of most Israelis you
realize there's no way that we're
descendants of anyone who lived in that
region you know where Europeans were
whites and I think it's pretty obvious
how we ended up Jews maybe an
interesting story for another time
obviously we're not descendents of HTTPS
nobody's been here for 3,000 years there
are as small Jewish communities that
have been in Hebron and in and it's
places like Jerusalem and a few other
small cities very small communities that
have been there for a long time I don't
think anybody's been there three
thousand years but it's part of the
mythology that it justifies the
so-called return or the emergence of the
Zionist state that justifies the
colonialism of Palestine the colonizing
of Palestine justifies yet the cleansing
and of course here we are again back to
this narrative where the Jews are a
righteous people that have a right to
return to Palestine the Palestinians
were the native people of the land have
no rights to live there and it's okay to
kill them and arrest them and forced me
to exile it's just one more component of
this of this mythology and maybe just to
wrap it up you know the entire Zionist
ideology is based on three minutes the
first myth is that Jews our nation as
opposed to being a religious group
within other nations
so you could have Jewish Germans Jewish
French Jewish Yemenites Jewish Moroccan
Jewish so forth Araki
the second myth is that the Bible is a
history book and we heard this again
said now but Israeli ambassador by
Netanyahu many times and other Israelis
but the Bible is a history book that
proves that Jews deserve Palestine well
the Bible is not a history book it's a
book of faith it's a religious document
but the Zionists who were never believed
in God and her were completely secular
people said that the Bible is the
history book of the Jewish people and
the third myth is that Palestine is the
Jew the homeland of the Jews and
everything else rests upon these three
myths and everything is justified by
falling back on these three myths and
everybody seems to just treat them as
though they were true so I think it's
important to have that in perspective
and realize these three myths are myths
that are not true they're created by
designers to know to justify what they
do and if we understand that then we
understand why things are the way they
are today
okay you see you see this happening the
world sees it happening what about the
international community what's the human
voice global voice saying doing how can
people who who want to stand up for
justice how can they make a peaceful
protest against this the call for
boycott divestment and sanctions the BDS
call it is a call by Palestinian civil
society to the world providing all of us
all people of conscience with a pathway
to resist
the oppression of Palestinians that to
bring about justice for Palestinians
it's a very dedicated very principled
nonviolent form of resistance South
Africans will tell you that BDS brought
down apartheid in South Africa I truly
believe that BDS will be maybe not the
force but certainly one of the major
forces to bring down the racist
apartheid regime in Palestine and will
help to free Palestine so in every
country in every community people of
conscience need to find the BDS group
the BBS branch and if there isn't one to
start one going BDS movement org and and
take a look at what they do they have
had campaigns now very large a very very
very successful campaign against HP that
campaigns are against other groups that
other organizations other companies that
work with Israel and support the Israeli
occupation of Palestine and this is what
people need to do you know starts by not
buying Israeli dates and end up by
boycotting big corporations like HP and
others who support Israel how could
people of consciousness I mean I think
every synagogue church mosque you know
should invite you to come on you know to
go ahead and educate many of the people
who are ignorant in this area are you
open to are you visiting places mosques
and I gods churches how could people get
a hold of you and to learn more you have
a book tell us about it
well the easiest thing is to send me an
email me capella at gmail.com or send me
a message on facebook I'm everywhere
this is
the general Sun just came out in a
second edition so it's it's it's got
more in it than the first edition does
and so we're very proud that we you know
it just came out second edition it's
easy to find me like I said on social
media or by email I do speak I'm happy
to speak and by speaking master speaking
you know any form that I'm invited to
and I'm happy to engage in this
conversation everywhere and with
everyone there you have it my friend my
co-pilot god bless you thank you so much
for being with us on a deal thank you
and thank you for tuning in subscribe if
you haven't already we'll see you next
time until then peace be with you